you must find a way to serve serve and
help people service to others is the
rent you pay for your room here on earth
what's up believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have Michael Jordan level
talent at something and I want you to
find it embrace it and use it to make a
difference now I started the one rule
series because I see a lot of tough tens
and there are rules that seem to come up
consistently over and over and over and
over again so the goal of this series is
to smush together the rules that are
most consistent packaged into one video
just for you so today we're gonna learn
how to find a way to serve joy you must
find a way to serve Martin Luther King
said that not everybody can be famous
but everybody can be great because
greatness is determined by service now
we live in a world where everybody wants
to be famous and where we admire people
for just being famous we think being
known brings us value the truth is all
of that will fade in time in three years
you won't be able to name the housewives
a banana the real truth is that service
and significance service and the
significance that you bring to your
service is that which is lasting so to
be able to whatever your occupation or
job or talent or gift is our honorees
today getting Doctorate degrees
- apparently opposite fields HIV and
AIDS and the spoken word but what they
have in common is service using the
spoken word in service to community in
the world using your knowledge and
information about HIV and AIDS and
medicine in service to the world and if
you look at all the most successful
people in the world whether they know it
or not they have that paradigm of
service everybody's talking about Mark
Zuckerberg and I appeal service jay-z
rapid
service through the word to people
through song for many years I was really
just happy to be on TV and people would
stop and say oh you on TV oh yeah I'm on
TV I like being on TV it's a nice job
and it was about the time that I
received my honorary Doctorate from
Spelman around 1993 so I don't know if
that had something to do with it I
thought of myself as dr. Winfrey then I
went back and I took the long look at
what it was I was doing on on TV and
made a decision that I was no longer
going to just be on TV but I was going
to use TV as a platform as a force for
good and not be used by TV and I will
tell you my decision to make that
significant change in the way I operated
on television using television as a
service changed my career exponentially
service through medicine service through
art using whatever it is you produce
your product as a way of giving back to
the world when you shift the paradigm of
whatever it is you choose to do to
service and you bring significance to
that success will I promise you follow
you service and significance equals
success that's number two and therefore
life is all about breathing
I read the meek breathing I was
mentioning this in the mantra lounge
last night
you can't just breathe in and keep the
breath there can you you can't just
breathe out and keep the breath there
can you the smooth rhythm of breathing
in Sanskrit is called he again the
fourth chapter of the bhagavad-gita
calls the smooth rhythm of breathing is
he again where you take to give you take
you give it's taking in giving out
taking in giving out yes we must take
because if you don't take how will you
give if you don't feel hope how will you
bring hope to someone we don't feel
loved how will you bring love to someone
if you don't feel uplifted how will you
uplift someone if you don't have
resources how will you share so have
take be successful earn a lot get bear
and serve give your time give your
resources give your mind give hope give
love give something so how do you define
success I think success is is is seeing
those around you work to their natural
best and creating momentum for a vision
towards a vision that will last beyond
yourself so a guy is driving a bus for
20 years got to retire he's on Madison
Avenue in New York packed every day as
people getting on that bus and getting
off mm-hmm yes two kids wife lives in
Queens hmm he might call himself
successful another guy might be vice
president of that company who call self
unsuccessful so his success what you
make of it so it's so this success is
defined its successes of feeling it's
not it's not a series of checkmarks and
goals
I think people define success as as
finish lines you know they well I ran a
marathon I am successful the question is
a why did you run the marathon and what
happens after you've completed the
marathon do you just keep running
marathons what happens if you break your
leg and you can no longer run marathons
you know we said a lot of people set
financial goals I'm successful when I
make my first million okay now I have to
make my second million its successes of
feeling and and it's the feeling of
contrib you
so your bus driver in Queens if he has
decided that his job as a bus driver is
to ensure that everyone who gets on his
bus feels better about themselves
because they got on his bus and not
another bus and so he greets them with a
smile he says good morning he says good
bye that people will remember that that
that that ride that they took with him
versus the this vice president of the
company who's made it about himself and
his financial goals
he's the one who's unhappy as opposed to
seeing those around him succeed and
those around him go home with a love of
their their day you know because they
come to work in his company every day so
I still believe success and and good
leadership are about service to others
when you went off on your own you know
that's kind of the point I think people
you know most businesses fail at the
beginning in the first few years so
there you are on your own what do you
think were the keys to success those
first few years by yourself
obsession without a more value than
anybody else ever dreamed of I mean my
entire life from the very beginning days
was how do I do more for others than
anyone else on earth how do I give them
experiences that are lasting how do I
create change were change was impossible
how do I take somebody from the therapy
for seven years in an hour produce that
result and the way I did that was by
challenging traditional psychologists
and psychiatrists and getting on
national radio and saying giving you
were stationed on handle in an hour
which was pretty abrasive you know as a
young kid you can get by with that stuff
but the best part was I backed it up and
so one of the first interventions I did
was in Vancouver British Columbia Canada
back on the radio and this psychiatrist
got on the phone and just on the radio
line I'm just crashing it you are a liar
you're a charlatan people like you
should not be allowed on the radio and I
said sir I said I said are you have you
know scientists he stood the course of a
physician I said well scientists would
never make it an a sumption as I said
you've never met me right no we'd never
do my clients no you're calling me a
liar on national radio I said she must
be standing or hypothesis your
hypothesis is that I've no wider to
Charlotte
you're setting up offices and you're
truly a scientist you gotta be willing
to test it
am i right yeah yeah it's a great night
doing a free guest event the Holiday Inn
tomorrow night anyone hearing my voice
can come I'm going to do a series of
demonstrations and I'm gonna take one of
your clients and turn around I said
share with me somebody that you've never
been able to change I said I'm sure you
got plenty of notes and you wanna play
hardball I play hardball because we were
one of patients that aren't ready to
change and I said I haven't found any
because I've been three therapies
absolutely please long story short he
told me this woman he'd been working on
for seven years
well the snake phobia a phobia is not
just a fear it's a mind control response
to fear so like she dreamed the snake
would bite her on the face and then the
adrenaline shoot through her body and
wake her up and there's an album 47
times a night seven years so you know he
was put in the corner and so he brought
her down and it took me about 15 minutes
at the end of it
I tested first and she's training and
shaking and then I wrapped the snake
around her and that changed my entire
career because in that moment every
there was no question everybody saw this
woman is transformed and I said you've
been treated but that's like my interest
how many years then I took on sports
stars so that I can't turn around you
know I did some work with Mother Teresa
Nelson Mandela Bill Clinton and as the
years went by it just built it up though
follow on Instagram and Facebook made
for PR did you really think that was a
good idea I know bro I honestly think
that that was one of like the worst
moves I've ever seen because I'm not
trying to razz you either I am talking
I'm trying to give you love I love the
passion to win the problem is you tried
to close on the first move you brought
them no value and you asked them to
bring you value like you gave like I
will stand up here and give a [ __ ] load
of value and never mention one time for
any of them to follow me and a lot more
of them will follow me then they're
gonna follow that bull move that you
just did
I get it I get it but this was back to
the question that just happened this is
why I want you to win that move is
always gonna lose you can't go tonight
when you go out in Vegas and you see a
pretty girl at the bar you can't go up
to her and the opening move is like
here's my key let's go but that's what
you just did let them hold it but that's
what you just did to this audience with
business I mean because doing the right
thing is the right thing
karma is practical you know I've heard
somebody rant earlier right that's like
hey when I win I don't think it's coming
out of you the guy that closed I
couldn't know who was on stage but I
believe in that right because I love the
idea of 85 people here going and
listening to me winning I didn't make
anything for it but it then becomes
brand if she goes down and listens and
then two years later she's having dinner
with a friend and she's talking about
what happened to her life that friend
might be the CEO of GE you know I'm
playing with the biggest brands in the
world I'm not trying to monetize my
audience I'm trying to like just bring
the most value in the world and let that
lift all my other opportunities so I
think I think giving away your best
secrets is the greatest strategy for two
reasons karma is practical and leads to
more business but here's the secret and
it's even funnier 99% of these people
are not going to do anything about it
the read somewhere about five or six
years ago I realized this fact Polish
people aren't gonna do anything with
this so it like there's still gonna be
plenty for me and I'm gonna be the most
lovable guy ever I love this so you know
how does it feel to be an inspiration to
many people who struggle with life does
he feel that pressure yeah that's an
intense question so he's in eighth grade
he would eighth grade yeah asking
existential questions about how people
feel or respond to me I don't think
about that actively because it's not I
don't I'm not what I don't do what I do
to have that effect because that would
imply that I wake up in the morning and
say how can I know I'm a perfect day for
me is when the phone does not ring and
when my inbox is empty that's a perfect
day and I can stay home play with the
kids watch a movie on the couch with
popcorn with slightly too much butter
and just veg but what happens is I get
called I get called by the press because
the universe flinched I get called by a
school you call by a city but by
organizers of a theater you know or
lecture halls and they want to learn
about the universe and in that capacity
I'm a servant of the public's curiosity
about the cosmos and in in that way I'm
not asking myself how am i affecting you
I'm simply offering all that I can and
all that I know of this beautiful
universe in which we live and that's
that's what I do and why everything in
your life happens for you not to you I'm
just a huge believer in that and so on
my baseball dream ended I had an injury
probably gave me a premature end to
occur that would have ended anyways
in hindsight because I played with
enough great players that I kind of know
there was a gap in just god-given
ability level not work ethic but yeah I
think to be the greatest there has to be
some proclivity for it and work ethic
right and so I kind of maxed out my
limited abilities and so when I got
released I ended up
back home with my parents I couldn't
find a job I was depressed I spent about
a year at my parents house just broke in
every way financially spiritually
mentally physically I remember my dad
came home my dad had just got sober and
my dad said to me hey I met this guy at
a meeting I got you a job you get your
ass down there tomorrow morning at 6
a.m. getting out of this house getting a
job and I'm like okay I have a college
degree
you know I'm being picky for a year
watching Maury Povich reruns everyday on
TV and Jerry Springer I go down there at
6:00 a.m. I walk in I said hey my name
is Eddie might let him here for the job
they're like what job I remember this
vividly right and I'm like I don't know
they just told me you know and they go
well we have no idea who you are and we
don't know what the job is they said do
you know who's hiring you I said I don't
remember and they go well then you need
to come back and I go to the door and I
go wait a minute
his name's Tim they're like there's a
lot of Tim's and I go well I know he
must be an alcoholic because he was at a
meeting with my dad laughter they go
drop Tim you know Tim right and where I
was was a place called McKinley home for
boys it was a group home a campus of
group homes all my boys were Ward's of
the court they were removed from their
family there because their parents were
incarcerated killed or were molesting
them and I ended up in cottage eight
cottage eight I had 12 boys they were 7
to 10 years old now walk through that
door that morning not even knowing what
the job was and it transformed my life I
mean in an instant brother I just saw
these eyes these little boys and they
just wanted someone to love them and
believe in them and care about them and
I'd have this big belief that people
that go through any dysfunction in their
family or abuse as a kid I think our
eyes are different we just have these
different eyes man and so I could
connect with these guys mine wasn't as
severe as theirs but I knew what it was
like to have that kind of anxiety and
that kind of stress and that kind of
pressure put on you as a little boy and
I became like their father I was there
with him on Christmas and Halloween and
their birthdays and I lived with them
and it changed my world because in that
instant I went from being this athlete
who was ego recognition significance
gonna get rich it's all about me always
when you're a good athlete you knew this
growing up was always accolades all of a
sudden in that instant it became about
serving people making a difference in
other than like oh this is
what makes me happy oh I was actually
born to serve and help people crazy no
one that never happened playing baseball
and while I worked there two years into
it
the financial business that I'm in came
along and I started in a part-time and
I'm the I was the rare young businessman
who approached the business world from a
place of service and giving and not
making money and ironically the more I
serve people the more I made a
difference the more I contributed the
more I was rewarded financially I didn't
do it for that reason but that's what
happened so that's how I got into the
business was actually and again
everything that my dad wasn't an
alcoholic he's not at that meeting I
don't get that job and if he wasn't if
it wasn't alcoholic I wouldn't have
connected with those boys so all of that
in hindsight happened for me right and
had I met the financial business before
that I'd have flown out of it I'd have
been about ego making money and when
that didn't happen out of left and so it
all happened in the right sequence most
people live their life like this they're
all over the place and they're unhappy
but when you know what your passion is
when you know what your purpose is your
life is a lot easier right you know who
you're supposed to hang out with and who
not to you know what opportunities to
take and which ones not to every
decision becomes easier and you're
living a life that is purposeful that is
happy you're adding value you're helping
people and you feel good and I want that
for everybody so how do you find it you
got to remember that your purpose is
gonna be a combination of something that
makes you happy with something that adds
a lot of value to other people's lives
you are happiest when you're serving
other people we are we are born and
meant to serve others right we feel
happy when we're helping somebody else
out with something and this can be
through a business or can be through
your job or whatever it is but you will
find your greatest pleasure and
happiness when you're adding value to
somebody's life so the combination of
what you love doing something that you
love doing so much something you you
wake up but you know say 9:00 in the
morning you start to work and it's you
look down you look back up in a six
nice like weirded where did everything
go where did the time go
because you're so in love with what
you're doing so think about all the
things that you love doing that you can
get lost in and then think about how you
combine that to help other people when
you can merge those two things together
that's when you find your purpose that's
when you find your path the things that
you love doing with the things that help
with the people that combination is
unique to you and when you find it
you'll feel amazing your life will
change everything will change at the
risk of sounding like a Miss America
contestant the most fulfilling things
I've experienced have truly been the
human interactions spending time with
women and village banks in Mexico with
Sync microfinance organization meeting
young women who were the first and only
in their communities to attend secondary
school in rural Kenya with free the
children a group that build sustainable
schools in developing countries trekking
with gorillas conservationists in Rwanda
it's a cliche because it's true that
helping others ends up helping you more
than anyone getting out of your own
concerns and caring about someone else's
life for a while
reminds you that you are not the center
of the universe
and that in the ways we are generous or
not we can change the course of
someone's life even at work the small
feats of kindness crew members directors
fellow actors have shown me have had the
most lasting impact service to others is
the rent you pay for your room here on
earth so be generous be kind be fair
it's not just the right thing to do it's
the good thing to do and I think we I
think we all can agree that with all the
tension in the world today that can
divide us we should be part of the
solution and not part of the problem and
you don't you don't have to make a
difference on a global stage you can
volunteer in your neighborhood or in
another neighborhood nearby where people
might look a little different from you
and they might teach you a thing or two
now I've got a really special bonus clip
around serving with Bejo school e'en
that I think you're really gonna enjoy
but before that I want to know question
the day whose message did you resonate
with more Oprah or Tony Robbins from
this clip Oprah or Tony Robbins let me
know your thoughts leave in the comments
below thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope I
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one where it is much loved
see you soon
someone asked me what's the number one
lesson I would like to give to myself if
I can go back 20 years in time right and
that lesson would be the lesson that I
already share with my kids right now see
I'm raising kids right now who are gonna
be entrepreneurs they're gonna be change
makers they're gonna be a useful part of
society and and I'm guessing that if
you're following me if you watch my
stuff that you subscribe to my channel
if you if you want anything to do with
me then you care about impact you care
about meaning you want to build an
empire that leaves a legacy behind them
for that to happen listen up young
entrepreneurs for that to happen you're
going to have to wake up every morning
and pick between one of two shirts the
other shirt that I used to pick to wear
every morning said what can you do for
me see I was a pretty selfish guy I was
a type of guy that always looked to you
and you and you and try to figure out
what can you do for me I'm gonna get
something for you how can I find the
loophole
where's the value in it for me these
days I wake up on it put on that shirt
that says how can I help you see the
more people you can help the most people
you can serve the more you'll get what
you want sig Ziegler said his best years
ago when he said the more you can help
others get what they want then you'll
get what you want right and so every
morning when you wake up you have one of
two shirts to wear you can either be
selfish and wear the shirt that says
what can you do for me or you can be a
giver a servant leader that says how can
I serve you and the more people that you
serve the better your life will be I
promise you and the bigger the Empire
you'll be building and the more impact
you'll make
best of all you'll have peace of mind
knowing that you're helping out humanity
which at the end of the day we're all
here on this planet to have some sense
of meaning right so wear that shirt how
can I help you if you tell yourself a
story long enough you start to believe
it don't you believe it you act like I
have Tulsa what a wail out of handcuffed
lightning though Thunder in jail now you
know I'm bad over the last week I
murdered a rock into the stone
hospitalized a brick I'm so mean I make
medicine sick the fundamental key to
success is it can take between 18 and
250 4 days of taking action for a new
habit to stick I've created a new course
called 250 for confidence or every
single day for 250 4 days I will be
sending you
a video between 30 seconds and five
minutes long that you start your morning
with around making you feel confident
it's absolutely free check out the link
in the description below to get access